so we're calling you sasha
yeah sasha zanari all right sasha
yes sasha where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um everywhere but i recently moved back
here
two years ago to florida
tell me about your family growing up um
a regular
pretty open family
my mom she's very sexual
very well she is yes so is that where
you get it from
yes i always see people looking at her
think that she looks pretty and stuff so
i'm like
i want to be like that of course she
wouldn't allow me to dress or be that
way but i just was taking quiet notes
but your parents were married
yes and are still married or yes they
are yes
so it's just a very no free sexual
yes i i don't know i didn't try to
exercise sexual stuff
but i knew i i knew that if i did try to
do it i don't think anybody would have
tried to stop me so
yeah and your sexual life started what
age
uh about 18 18 so fairly normal
normal yes 18 years old i i didn't have
sex until then but once
but i knew leading up to that 16th
century i knew that i wanted to like
like okay my dad he used to have like
these porn magazines
so i would see them under the sink in
the bathroom and i'm like
i want to be in one of those they were
doing all these crazy things like
peeing on stuff like a lot of stuff you
know and i'm like i want to do that
i like that so i knew you think you got
that from your mom
i didn't get that from my mom i got it
from a magazine under my dad's scene but
i felt like
my mom does that when i go to sleep i
don't know um but i'm like
hey they look happy so it was just
something that when i got older i knew
i i went through my life not being too
sexual but i knew once i got 18 and i
got on my own and i was able to do my
own thing
i was going to be like that i knew that
i knew i wanted to be in playboy
i had all of these ideas of things that
i wanted to do
however once i got 18 i said i don't
want playboy to be the end-all be-all
i want a little bit more i want to see
what i can do so i actually got into um
being a stream-mate model and from there
you can't model yes my whole entire
sexual world opened up my income opened
up my freedom opened up
everything opened up because before that
i was just working
regularly a regular worker and i
actually went to school i graduated when
i was 16 and i went to college
and once i got 18 i was like oh wait a
minute this is something here
i like this this is a way to make money
and i don't have to leave
my house i don't have to do anything
like that so i liked it and when i first
started i was making
about uh 500 a week and that was okay
for me for an 18 year old
and um i lived alone and um
i just i was doing well i was never
behind my bills were paid everything was
okay
and i would literally just open up my
laptop turn on my camera
talk to people sometimes it's a little
bit more than that
but you know once i saw that i couldn't
make income from it i said i don't want
this to be all i don't want to
cage myself in with this i want to do
something more so from that from the
streaming
um i actually had a regular person that
would see me often
he actually told me hey my wife and i
were having a
swing wedding and i didn't know what
that was so i tried to be cool and act
like i knew what it was
and um i asked what it was and he told
me
the gist of it basically they were going
to have a mock wedding they had been
married for 20 years
and they wanted to have a fake wedding
but everybody would be naked
so that was my first introduction into
swing i was hosting that
wedding basically i didn't involve
myself with anything i don't want you to
be like so wild orgy or something like
that
it was i just wasn't in it but but
that's what exposed you to
your lifestyle yeah and i wasn't looking
at it like this is terrible this is bad
i was looking at it like that person's
having sex with their husband
that person's having sex with their
husband while that person is also doing
it
and everybody's cool with that it looked
like some type of scene out of a greek
movie or something i don't know it was
just i
i felt weird because i was the only one
sitting there not doing anything
so but that was my first introduction
into um swing lifestyle yeah
and so you're married currently yeah
you've been married for how long over a
decade
and your husband's cool with this he's
he knew
that i was into um he didn't know that i
was into like swing world because i
wasn't in a swing world because i didn't
have anybody to swing with
i could have been a unicorn which is
someone who's a single woman
who goes into swing and she seeks out
other couples and things like that but
i've never been that
um once we got together uh we married
about two years later
and he said hey um what is this about
when i would because he would come over
and i worked as a cam girl
and i didn't want to tell him at first
because i i lied i really liked him
and i'm just like i don't know if he's
like square or how he's gonna take this
or how it's gonna go
so i told him about it and he goes i
like that i really like that
and before that he um we lived in the
same um
condo area and the complex and he
actually would see me
but only like you know every now and
again coming from my car going to my
house and i typically dress like this
so he just assumed as a neighbor he
lived like
two buildings down that i was a stripper
he just thought that about me so when
he finally got over to talk to me or say
something nice to me he goes um are you
a stripper and i said no
why he said because everybody who lives
in your building is and i said oh that's
nice they're really pretty women i
didn't know that
and um we started talking and i told him
what i did i didn't tell him i was a
trip i just told him no i don't trip i
haven't have a real job
and um the more we started to talk when
he would just like show up
to my home unannounced he would see like
this huge box lighting
or these cameras and stuff because i had
really
like had my setup game together after a
while you know and he would just be like
what's going on in here
so then i started to tell him and he
goes why did you think you needed to
hide that from me and
i was like okay cool i i was like i
don't know i'm an adult he's an adult
why would i feel the need to hide
from another adult and i don't know i
felt silly
because i spent like eight months of my
life hiding that and he was just like do
that but then
after we had been dating for about a
year he said you should grow
from that like do something more like
don't you want to do something else and
he started
researching how to get me in certain
magazines and do certain stuff just
asking me what i wanted to do he
encourages it yeah
yeah rather than feeling threatened by
it yeah yeah he doesn't
he's never said don't do that he'll say
something is not a good look for the
brand sometimes they'd be like
we're not going to do that we're not
doing that one but but
aside from a business like just
personally you guys will go to
yes we go yeah with with no camera with
no nothing we
uh we probably go to news news resorts
about
once a week if not three but for sure
once
for sure once because you'll go to these
parties and you'll meet somebody new and
different
uh-huh i typically go for um a newbie
night when
their people are new you know and then i
typically go again for karaoke nights i
love to sing and i don't sing well so
everybody's drunk and i look i sound
good so i typically go for karaoke night
and then i go again for newbie night
because i like to meet who's new
in swing because sometimes well i not
sometimes a lot of the time i have a
habit of helping people navigate their
way through this life
because i haven't had any bad things
happen yet
but i've seen some girls getting really
lost
really lost as unicorns really lost as
um just
generally they don't they think that you
have to jump in here and just start
sleeping with people to not to make rank
because there is no rank in swing but
there is like a like when you come
places people do know you
you know what i mean so like if we were
like at the spot right now people would
know who i
who i was so sometimes when i go and
it's newbie night and i see like a
nervous person
in the corner i always just run over and
grab them and i sit with them for the
whole night
and then when people see them sitting
with me they typically
try to be lying to that person and then
i leave them alone
at these parties you'll end up with
another partner your husband will end up
with some other girl
uh typically when i go there my my
husband and i were really really into
each other
so it does get to that point sometimes
but it's people think that it's like
every time you go somewhere
you're hooking up with someone no that's
irresponsible it sounds crazy
if if you were living a a regular
monogamous life
without a person and you were just
looking for someone you wouldn't be
sleeping with someone every day you
wouldn't be
so in swing you don't sleep with someone
every day we're not these super hyper
sexual
human beings that people who try to make
it out
is the assumption yes it is it is but i
mean sexuality does
secrete from your pores sometimes it
does and sometimes i just want to be
normal i just want to go
have a good time at a phone party and
then people are like humping on my leg
and i'm like nah
so is it just a way to spice up your
your relationship with your husband
no my relationship was really really
spicy before um the first time that we
ever had a situation
um we get really into each other when
it's just us but the first time that we
ever had a situation
is uh we were at a boat party with our
friends it was just one other couple
and um we had all been drinking and
having a good time and
i just was the one who was like we're
stepping this up i don't even know if
the people that we were there with were
swingers i just
know that she was an adult life that
doesn't necessarily mean someone is okay
with seeing you
getting it on so you have to respect the
boundaries you kind of got to just gotta
know or just predict you know so
we were on a boat for a party just for a
little get together having drinks and
everybody was pretty jacked up so i just
started like dancing
lots of spanish music having a good time
and i started like
oh this is youtube
i started like taking off my husband's
clothes basically from the waist down
and just doing my own thing you know and
thank god i don't i don't i like i said
i don't know if my friends that those
particular set of friends were swingers
but thank god good friends don't let
friends suck dick alone
because she was like she just whipped
gangs up her husband pulled down his
pants he's doing him she's i'm doing her
husband
and we're doing our own thing then my
husband and her husband are looking at
each other like
what is going on my husband knows that
i'm like
sneaky because i will like scoot over in
a pool and sit on him or something like
that but it's never like
bam here it is even if we're at a nude
resort i'll scoot over in the jacuzzi or
we'll
go into someone's car in the car lot or
something like that so this particular
time was the first time that my husband
was like
okay we can't go back from that all
right so
my friend she's doing her thing and they
the guys
look at each other and are like i don't
know how far this is supposed to go like
what is
what is this you know and they just flip
it over
you know it just ended like that so it
wasn't a swap but it was a swing
situation you know what i mean so but
i can honestly say i am not afraid
to be intimate while other people watch
and i'm okay
with them watching because i don't
practice having sex but i do
like work on how i move my body and
fluid like just being really fluid so
when i know someone
is watching me i'm like oh yes okay this
is good this is really good this is this
is happening so
the majority of your or maybe all of
your sexual interactions are with your
husband
yes for sure but you like being around
other couples that are doing yes
while it's happening yes i'm okay with
that it doesn't happen often
because i'm picky with who who i
want to see like who i want to see me
anybody can see me i don't care for you
it's more about being watched
that too for being seen i guess and i
like seeing other people do live
and your husband enjoys that as well yes
i don't know if he enjoys seeing other
people or not but i know that he enjoys
when other people see me and they're
like wow she's very beautiful or wow
she's very
talented or something like that because
even sometimes people will come up to my
husband and go well they don't come up
to him but
come up to me while i'm with him um even
when we were in home depot the other day
somebody goes
wow you're really pretty i feel like i
know you what do you do i said i'm an
adult artist
and he goes okay wow maybe i have seen
you i said maybe you have
and then he goes why do you do that
because some people assume you do
because you need money or you're
desperate or you're just like some
freaky nympho maniac or something like
that
i said because i'm really good at it
said okay and he just walks off and i'm
like okay you know why do you choose to
work here
the home people that you're working at
like because you're really good at it
you're really good at pointing and
saying i don't know
that's i'm not the manager you're really
good at that so
this is just hap this just so happens to
be what
i'm really really good at and like being
a
a cam model and it segway into me being
in swing life
and people in swing love me and i love
them and we make
so many good lifelong friends
dentists doctors um
we met someone in swing who's a dentist
and i chipped my tooth and he's like hey
come over and i go in his garage and
he's making like dentures
in his garage like he's they're really
awesome people and i'm like okay
cool the communities there yeah i don't
know what
community i think you hang out at a
different community than what i was at
last time
i've been there before yes and that vibe
is exactly the same i can tell you it is
almost the same
around the board but that vibe is really
similar
yes yeah very very pleasant very free
very easy
nobody's freaked out and being weird it
just seems to be very healthy almost
yes for lack of a better word yes and
when you explain that to not when you
explain that because sometimes when
people ask what do i do i just say i
don't know do you wanna come to my job
with me
or do you wanna come with me or do you
want to see and there's times where like
i have my own studio at home while i
set up my camera i have my lighting and
everything and um i just stream i sit
there in my bikini
you know until i'm private or whatever
the case may be
and there's sometimes where i have like
a family member or something like that
and they
i've actually brought my family members
to the nudist resort before a few of
them
and i think that they probably thought
it was going to be crazy and people are
just going to be
doing stuff i think that's that's the
square assumption
yeah and when they walked in we went to
the club portion first and so nobody was
naked everybody was scantily dressed and
i just started dancing everybody's
coming up to me hugging me and asking
questions and things like thinking what
was your inexperienced
friend they said do you know these
people i said no
to my family member i was a cousin and
it was a cousin two wait three cousins
actually two boys and a
big female cousin how did it go and um
they at first when we got there they're
like okay they haven't drink so we got
there first
so i made sure we got there early before
anybody came in so we could set the tone
i got my table set up
got my drinks bartender's my friend i
typically work there so i'm not working
tonight so i said i'll bring you guys to
my job so you can see what i do when i'm
not working
working as a bartender as a host host so
basically host just gets on the mic make
sure everybody's having a good time
walk around kiss a couple of people in
the mouth i don't know suck a couple of
nipples and move on with your life
that's what
i'll do make sure everybody's having a
good time that's what they do they pay
you
10 15 for that and then you go you know
and um
about my family we started having drinks
early everybody's just drinking little
tequila having a good time and then
everybody starts
turning up a little bit they start
seeing certain stuff going on you know
and they're like okay so people just
started first walking up to me talking
to me and they said do you know them i
said no i don't
they know me because i typically work
here so once it starts you know the
party is just going i'm dancing i'm all
over the place i'm feeling buds i'm
going up skirts
and my family is like we do not see you
act like this like what is going on here
i'm like that's
okay but they weren't showing it on
their faces that they were
scared or anything they were just like
whoa having a good time glowstick's
having a great time so then after
when we go out to the pool area i said
you guys having a good time they're like
what the hell is going on here i was
like
everything and you love it and it's okay
so
they had an experience they're not
swingers but they've had an experience
there and they're just like
this is really fun and it's like you
have the option to get into things
if you want to nobody's walking up to
you the respect level is just so there
it really is just still there yeah i i i
feel that
as well it seems like that community
is very like you can do it if you want
to and you don't if you
don't if you want to watch that's cool
and if you want to join in that's cool
and it's very laid back and easy
for sure for sure and i love it i'm i
don't see myself
um getting out but i see myself evolving
within because a lot of my friends they
are
very much older i'm long in the tooth
myself but they are
longer in the tooth and they are living
happy lives they have been married 30
and 40 years
so to me it's just like when i see that
to me i i love that i love that i've
always when i was a kid
i wanted to to live in a house and have
a marriage
where everybody has the same last name
where everybody is just
happy and feeling loved and there is not
this stress or
none of that you know i grew up in a
normal household we didn't have like
above the means we just had what we
needed you know so to me it's just like
i don't want
excess but i just want to evolve i want
to grow and while i'm doing that i don't
want to miss a moment
of of anybody's life my life my
husband's life our family's life or
anything like that so it's like this job
does
free me up to do anything anything i
want to do and i love it i really do
yeah i met your husband you guys seem
very happy and
healthy and normal and very cool mm-hmm
it'd be easy to like detect that he's
got a very you know weird attitude or
something and he doesn't
what you said that you think it would be
very easy for me to detect that there's
some weirdness going on with you guys
yeah yeah and there isn't no i can tell
you that he's really awesome
i can kind of intuit that that you guys
are happy and healthy with each other
just when you think that we've done
everything in this
life like i want to be in every category
of adult world i do
so right now i am a stream artist um a
stream made model
or cam girl i have to make sure i'm
saying this correct a cam girl
um i do do like only fans i have a
slew a community of foot fetish people
that fully support i know it sounds
crazy that fully support me in my feet
i could live off of my face mark i could
live on my feet you guys are into that
again
guys yes so i have a slew of them and
it's like i'm
trying to get and dabble into everything
that i want to
that i'm not and your husband's attitude
is it's all cool it's the same way the
minute that i think that
i'm like this is good i like this amount
of money i like this this place where we
are
he's like no we gotta do this this is
you gotta kick it up because
yeah he's like he doesn't tolerate it he
encourages it yes he does encourage it
he does he's like you just
if you're already out there and people
are already judging you just
do whatever it is you want to do and
typically people don't judge me they do
initially
and then they say oh my god you're a
really nice woman you're a really nice
lady
and i'm like hey thank you and florida
seems to be big on the swinger community
and the nudist clubs and all that
that's why i ended up getting a place
here we never um
i didn't think we were just going to
move here we would come and visit and do
a lot of parties and i would get booked
here a lot and host here but once i got
here
i said oh my god we need to look for a
place here what are the clubs that you
frequent um nude beach violin the uh
secrets top secrets and um
um what is it
the other the other the other um
paradise
or paradise and i've been to caliente
once and i
love love love it but i don't feel like
i was able to experience it in whole
because i was there visiting a friend of
mine and she had like a
suite so i didn't really there's a bunch
of them here yeah
and we're in orlando yes
currently in tampa and orlando seem to
have a lot of these
yes and also they're a little bit
different from each other
but the vibe is always the same a lot of
parties happen privately as well they
have like treehouse parties
i've hosted parties at um like i don't
know i'm not gonna say his name i have a
friend
who has a mansion in caliente and a lot
of parties occur at his home
so that's why i say when i go to
caliente i'm not ever like on the
premises
and doing stuff like i want to i'm
typically like
hosting and contractually obligated to
stay wherever i am
do you feel like the united states in
general is is an uptight
community uptight country sexually
i enjoy being naked i enjoy my cheeks in
the wind
and other people don't like that here
and it's a problem
and um even here in florida yeah yeah
well
not so much i dress exactly how i want i
don't know if you follow me on instagram
but
i dress exactly how i want wherever i go
and nobody says a thing
maybe they look when i'm not looking but
no one says a thing but before
as to when i was living elsewhere no
i've been booked in idaho before and
they were i had to do like a burlesque
show in idaho once and they were like
explaining it to me and they we i
actually met this couple at um
a nude resort and he was a concert
promoter and he says to me i would like
to book you and i said okay cool i said
you know what i do correct and he's like
oh your strippers said no i don't do
that
i said but i am v but i can dance very
well
and so i had seen a number that i had
done on stage so it was like a burlesque
very ballet type of situation and he's
like could you do that
not um scantily dress i said absolutely
so i put together a routine and i was
hiding behind this giant fan
and it was really cool but i was really
nervous about that because
i'm in idaho and it's very conservative
and it was like
what in the amish
thank god i had my hat on when i got
there because i was like oh my god i
don't know what's going to happen here
but they
loved it and they hugged me after the
hugs meant more than the payment
because i was just like i just want to
get out of here but after i was
it was like a slow 80s championship clap
but then it just was like
for you it's just a business but it's
more more importantly it's a lifestyle
yeah if i didn't get paid i'd still do
it yeah i'd still do it
but i thank god every day that i am able
to to to
be compensated financially for it but if
i didn't i would still do it
just because it's just what i want to do
i want to wake up and do what i want to
do
you know yeah so so you you
like people get upset that i'm what's
her instagram what's her cam thing i
don't i don't want to promote i don't do
that
i don't the people that need to know you
know me my i see my viewers give me a
hard time for not not promoting people's
no social values but my viewers need to
understand that the whole reason i'm
doing this channel
or one of the main reasons i'm doing
this channel is a reaction
to my advertising career which is what
advertising is about it's about
promoting it's about promoting it's
about promoting
and i don't enjoy promoting any longer
i no longer promo i don't promote i just
pop up and
yeah but but i love people i love
people's lifestyles i love people's
personalities and that's really what i
love to show yeah and my viewers can
figure out who you are and they'll find
your
cam model channel there's someone go
find your instagram
oh my god because this is the first i
don't want to offend you if i said this
okay
this is the first square thing i've ever
done i've done interviews before i've
done
other things before but this is just
like any old body could see this
interview yeah yeah your mom
but she's no i'm sending her the links
when she drives she's going to be like
look i've learned my viewers are very
smart and they're very resourceful and
they'll figure out who you are
yeah they're not stupid what does your
family feel about this
um i think my p you would think that
people would say i didn't raise you to
be a
porn star your mom was already like yeah
but she didn't raise me to be that way
either but nobody raises anybody to be a
police officer nobody raises anybody to
be a
veterinarian you are who you are you are
whatever you just
transform into you know you have sisters
you have brothers
i am one of eight and my all of my
siblings know
um my dad knows my mom knows and
my siblings they don't ask a lot they my
i think my mom explains it to them as
your sister because i'm the older
your sister is um does whatever she
wants
like they just that's just the thing you
know and whatever they need i make sure
that
at thanksgiving they just roll their
eyes at you and tolerate it or they
kind of enjoy no one cares they love
they love me yeah no one cares
i love that they hear me they are
they're texting me they're like you're
very lonely
i love you your husband's a very lucky
man i told them right
i don't think anybody's shaming me but
my family they there's nothing about you
to be ashamed about
yeah i don't think but i'm sure america
will find ways to hate you
or love you they're gonna do both i can
see it but i'm okay with all of this you
know i'm okay
i think you're very cool thank you
sasha thank you very much
any time you're amazing
thank you can i charge my nails so you
can cut off the lights and show them
because they go on the dark
they glow in the dark sure let me turn
it away
[Music]
thank you very much for having